beyonce beyonce
beyonce just call her grammy's queen
with black is king
[Music]
nine nominations for that album
including record of the year
in fact with 79 total career nominations
beyonce is the most nominated female
artist in grammy history
taylor's going head-to-head with beyonce
for song of the year swift nab
six nods today these are things that
make me break out in a full body sweat
[Music]
taylor is also up for album of the year
for folklore today
ex harry styles scored his first ever
grammy noms including for best pop vocal
album
pitting him against taylor
[Music]
six nominations she got the surprise
news this morning
congratulations you're joking billy
island
remember back in january when this teen
swept the grammys
duh i could have bet you money that that
would never happen
i got everything today billy eilish got
everything she wanted
four nominations billy's tied with best
new artist nominee
grammy newby megan the stallion who
heard the news
while announcing today's nominations i'm
a savage
so congrats what would it mean to you
to hear your name on the morning of the
nominations for the grammys
i will be genuinely excited like i will
be
probably jumping out of my body oh my
god
what but what about today's snubs
[Music]
love didn't rain down for lady gaga or
the biebs in the top three categories
justin did get a nod for changes but
posted quote
not being acknowledged as an r b album
is very strange to me
and while we all expected grammy
fireworks for the weekend
who won three amas on sunday today he
got
nothing
[Music]
he's super busy anyway grammy weekend
gearing up for the super bowl halftime
just one week later
and only e.t has an exclusive sneak peek
at the weekend's official live
performance video of faith before it
hits viva
[Music]
shocked that the weekend was snubbed um
but back to the grammys for a second
trevor noah
is going to host and i think he's going
to knock it out of the park the grammys
air
january 31st on cbs